fatalement ça recule dans les premières
patientes et ici ça veut mais on a comme
on doit le département des yvelines
possède dorénavant sa propre maison des
femmes situé sur un site du centre
hospitalier de plaisir la maison calypso
a ouvert ses portes fin janvier sa
mission écouter soigner et accompagner
toutes les femmes en difficulté ou
victimes de violences les femmes en ont
une adresse c'est une bonne nouvelle on
sait que 100 femmes par an meurent sous
les coups de leur conjoint la plupart du
temps
pour que qu'est ce qu'on fait on on se
bouche les oreilles ont fait fermer les
yeux parce que on se dit fier de compter
non on ouvre une maison on les accueille
et puis on se réjouit qu'elle faisait un
lieu la maison calypso accueille
également un centre de planification
familiale pour répondre à toutes les
questions liées à la vie amoureuse et à
la sexualité où on trouve une table
gynécologique un appareil dé qu ici on
réalise des consultations de
contraception des consultations pour un
éventuel avortement et puis
le dépistage des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles
sur place les femmes peuvent également
avoir des rendez vous avec une
assistante juridique ou une conseillère
conjugale ça sera une salle qui sera
utilisé pour des permanences on va
proposer aux femmes aussi un accueil
juridique en fait pour se rendre par une
juriste qui va les renseigner sur
l'accès au droit et puis on a tissé des
liens aussi avec le commissariat de
plaisir où il ya une intervenante
sociale qui viendra une fois par semaine
informer les femmes sur le dépôt de
plainte qu'est ce que c'est que déposer
plainte à quoi ça m'engage et puis faire
du lien du coup avec le commissariat
pour que les femmes aient une démarche
qui soit un petit peu simplifié si elle
souhaite déposer plainte soutenue par le
département des yvelines est porté par
le groupement hospitalier de territoire
yvelines sud la maison calypso a déjà
accueilli une vingtaine de patientes
bientôt l'équipe proposera des ateliers
de danse de théâtre ou des groupes de
paroles pour compléter la prise en
charge individuelle et amener les femmes
à se reconstruire